what questions should we ask you that
we're not asking why am I here we think
we know the answer to that question to
do this why am I here now that sounds
terribly abstract but in reality we
don't know why we're here we don't even
know what here is we have no
understanding or true understanding of
what a human being is and if we have no
true understanding of what a human being
really is really I don't mean like sort
of I don't mean like they teach us in
stupid school I don't mean like what
coaches tell us and consultants tell us
and and personal growth people tell us I
don't mean all that crap I mean really
so why am I here you know that old
question Who am I and the minute you
begin to ask questions that everybody
shuts off or it gets very very quiet in
the room and it gets very very quiet in
the room Evan because there's an innate
understanding that I don't know who I am
or why I'm here and because I don't know
who I am and why I'm here I have all of
these other seeming problems of being
dissatisfied with how I am here and then
I become distracted by a whole subset of
want 11111 which takes me away from the
question Who am I why am I here to how
can I get what I want how can I get what
I want how can I
get what I want and in fact all of the
millions of buyers of my books i would
suggest bought my books to get what they
want why most small businesses don't
work and what to do about it my business
doesn't work I want my business to work
so I can be happier so I can have more
money so I can have more free time so i
can get so i can get you follow me all
for the wrong reason so everybody does
everything for the wrong reason well
that leads me to ask the question so
what's the right reason so you
understand if we got involved in these
kinds of questions something could
happen that can't happen when people ask
all the questions that they asked so
when my wife says to me lose delia says
to me Michael you're always asking
answering a question nobody asked up
second yeah but I'm answering the
question he should have asked because
underlying the question he did ask is
this question he didn't ask because he
didn't know to ask it which then
suggests he's going to discover
something deeper more meaningful more
genuine more authentic as he pursues the
questions and the answers and the
process I'm leading him to and that's
not my narcissism or my ego saying that
it says freakin true